uh these are the questions that people
are asking what are your plans for
unicorn island you can ask the first one
too i see it i thought you said you saw
it i thought you skipped out of respect
it says what's your female type yeah we
love that question i've never talked
about this actually i so those of you
are listening i came out at the very
tender age of 30. that was a lot of fun
especially
i think coming out is probably a tough
decision for anybody to make but i would
imagine seeing how tight-knit your
family is and also in you have kind of
uh in your culture
um i think that
well you you're a disrupter of your
whole culture i think women in your
culture are not as i often think to
myself why don't you just pick a
struggle girl like why are you doing
that you know what i mean because i
really am out here just being like i
need all the therapy but yes no for sure
i it was hard to come out at 30. hard to
come out as a brown person heart to come
out as someone in the public eye uh the
day after i came out as bi it was the
number one trend on twitter so i opened
my phone and twitter it was right there
in my face and i wanted to throw up i
think i did throw up actually to be
completely honest because i felt so just
strange about that um but i now what
made you come out like what was the
what was that defining moment where you
go i'm gonna share that now yeah i think
because you don't have to no you're
absolutely right but i had a fear of
because i like i said i share so much of
myself online i really didn't want this
to come out through a different way i
wanted me to be the one that said it and
i wanted it to come out in a celebratory
way because i really do feel like
there's a lot of stories of people
coming out that are very sad and they're
very valid and emotional and needed but
i didn't want mine to be that i wanted
to control the narrative and say hey i'm
proud of this i want to celebrate this
especially because i come from a culture
where there was so much pain involved in
that process i wanted to show a
different way of doing it
the reason i decided to come out at that
age is honestly because i came to terms
with with it to myself at that age very
very late growing up in toronto in high
school i didn't know a single queer
person no one in my high school was
queer or identified in careers when i
went to university i knew one queer
person in all of york university um i
was sure there was more well that was
out that i knew of and they were nothing
like me so it really wasn't until i was
a full-fledged doubt that i adult that i
was even introduced to the concept of
queerness or queer people and so that
helped me learn about myself and i
literally admitted it to myself
like months before i tweeted about it so
it wasn't like a years and years of me
okay so you come to the realization did
you share with your parents before you
tweeted so like a type a personality
person the moment i said it to myself
and my dog i gave myself 30 days to tell
every single person i needed to tell in
my life i made a to-do list and i told
every person 30 people sound like my
daughter i was like okay 4 p.m on friday
i'm gonna have to have this conversation
that was me i'm saying my parents did
know
who did you tell first mom or dad i told
my dog and then i told i did did you did
you swear your dog to secrecy i did i
was like you tell anyone i swear to god
you go straight to the kennel
but i told uh my closest friends from
toronto first and then slowly i told
people here and there wasn't a long list
it was like 10 people my parents were
the last on that list and i was quite
nervous about that
and were they both on the phone what was
it no i did it in person were they both
in the room i wrote a letter and i
dropped it in front of them and i went
upstairs and cried that's honestly what
happened and then and then what seemed
like an eternity passed by and they came
up and honestly
they did the best they could have done
at that moment my mom hugged me that
doesn't matter to me what did the letter
say
the letter
oh my god i don't even remember but i'll
tell you the funny thing about the
letter is i was at my parents house and
the only printer in the whole house is
my dad's printer so i had to put the
letter on his computer save it on his
hard drive use his printer to print it
then wipe his hard drive what font does
one use times new roman you keep it
basic you keep it basic something they
understand there's already so many new
concepts in this letter now we don't
need the font to be another one
um but yeah you know i i they did the
best i could have done and i think we
both needed some time to kind of adjust
this new normal did they accept it
right away
accept is not the right word they did
accept because i'm their daughter and
they made it abundantly clear that they
love me no matter what that's just what
did they understand this concept
honestly not completely and did you
understand that that's what i'm saying
and i think in that moment if i'm being
really honest i actually write about
this in my book i write about this very
honestly
i think one of the obstacles of that
time and why i had so much so much
turmoil after is i instantly expected
perfection from everyone i told i think
i was so vulnerable that i wanted my
parents to say every textbook right
thing i wanted them to understand right
away and that was never going to happen
these are people that grew up in a
different time a different place have
never heard of what's interesting is
that was your expectation having been a
major in psychology
you would understand that we are foibles
so my logic says that but at that time i
was just so scared and nervous and
vulnerable and maybe i deep down
subconsciously wanted a distance a
little bit so i could figure myself out
so i created this little bit of like oh
you didn't say this right thing and they
were like we love you it doesn't matter
and so now i can say you've met my
parents they came to canada's got talent
beautiful where we are now is such a
beautiful place of them learning me
learning us meeting in a common ground
and me really learning that
people being from two opposite sides of
a subject you can meet in the middle i
know in today's day and age we feel
that's impossible always like you're
this i'm this you're red i'm blue i'm
this but i really do feel like through
education compassion and learning you
can meet in the middle and that has been
the story of my life with coming up and
so now i'm in a place that's so
beautiful with my parents and i have
such a great relationship
that's pretty fun